Радянського Союзу давно вже немає, а Совєтськ є.
Тихе провінційне російське місто зберегло радянські традиції.
Першотравень цього року тут святкували з розмахом,
у місті пройшла багатотисячна демонстрація.
У ній традиційно взяли участь працівники бюджетних установ,
зокрема технікумів, шкіл і навіть дитячих садків.
Головна відмінність Совєтська від сотень інших російських міст -
з іншого боку річки Німан, за цим мальовничим мостом,
починається Литва, Євросоюз і східний кордон НАТО.
До Таураге - першого великого міста з литовського боку -
близько 30 кілометрів.
Там перше травня - теж офіційний вихідний, але його майже не святкують.
До Другої світової війни Таураге входив до складу
незалежної Литви, а Совєтськ був східно-прусським Тільзітом.
Потім обидва міста опинилися в СРСР.
Але нині відмінності між ними помітні неозброєним оком.
По обидва боки збереглося чимало історичних будівель.
У Таураге вони відреставровані.
У Совєтську більшість руйнується.
Михайло Боєв - історик, який народився і виріс у Совєтську.
Він каже, що саме тут, у колишньому Тільзіті,
значно більше шедеврів архітектури.
Але місцева влада майже нічого не робить,
щоб відновити будівлі. На відміну від сусідів.
- Прірва є, і вона збільшується.
Це не якась ментальна прірва, а в плані ставлення до стану міста.
Там дійсно відбувається розвиток,
з'являються сучасні місця, доглянуті майданчики.
Там більше ремонтується будівель.
Там приємно перебувати. Там сучасні міста з розвиненою інфраструктурою.
Совєтськ і Таураге - міста-побратими.
Ще кілька років тому у сусідів
із російської і з литовської сторони було чимало спільних проектів.
Багато оплачував Євросоюз у рамках транскордонного співробітництва.
Наприклад, у парку Совєтська відновили
ось цей пам'ятник королеві Пруссії Луїзі,
яка була бабусею російського імператора Олександра Другого.
Але тепер таких спільних проектів дедалі менше.
До розпаду СРСР жителі двох міст пересувалися між ними вільно.
Сьогодні між сусідами і навіть родичами дедалі менше контактів.
Ось так кордон виглядає нині.
Жодного ажіотажу з охочих перетнути його немає.
Перехід займає всього кілька хвилин.
На автомобілі з урахуванням контролю - до однієї години.
Хоча на свята тут і бувають черги з автомобілів,
статистика литовської прикордонної служби красномовно свідчить
про скорочення комунікації між сусідами.
Лише за останній рік кількість переходів у селищі
Панямуне знизилася приблизно на 10%,
і така тенденція намітилася вже давно.
- Більше перетинають кордон громадяни Росії,
тому що з литовської сторони потреби особливої туди їздити немає.
Частина литовців їздять за якимись покупками,
але це дуже невелика частина.
Хтось - за бензином, за якимись товарами їде.
Кількість литовців, які їздять туди, скорочується з року в рік.
Майже рік тому тут побудували новий
прикордонний термінал підвищеної пропускної здатності.
Його планували відкрити ще до чемпіонату світу з футболу в Росії,
але, за словами литовців, Москва затягує відкриття.
Чому жителі сусідніх міст майже не їздять один до одного?
Думки у місцевих з цього приводу різні.
- Є родичі там, але зустрічаємося досить рідко.
- А чому?
- Трошки різний менталітет і вони в Литві не особливо раді росіян бачити.
- Ну а що там робити взагалі? Я тут працюю, тут живу.
- Чи буваєте там?
- Ні.
- А чому?
- Бували раніше, але потрібно робити візу. А зараз можливості немає.
- Дорого виходить?
- Так, виходить дорого.
- Я не їжджу туди. Нам тепер візи потрібні, проблем більше.
Раніше їздив. Якщо візи не були б потрібні, можна було б їздити,
у мене там двоюрідна сестра живе.
- Раніше було так, що легше було поїхати в Росію.
А тепер потрібні візи. То якщо не треба їхати, то й не їдеш.
- Я сам не відчуваю якоїсь шкоди від Росії,
але фейкові новини, які вони поширюють у нас,
згубні для нашої країни. І я вважаю за краще їздити не в Росію, а в Європу.
Більшість опитаних людей називають серед головних проблем
не тільки візовий бар'єр, але й ментальний.
Але чи тільки в цьому справа?
Історик і директор музею в Таураге Ромулдас Ваіткус каже:
ще кілька років тому між обома країнами
було значно більше програм культурного обміну,
а нині вони скорочуються.
- Відносини стають холоднішими.
Раніше було легше все робити, відносини були кращими.
Я сам уже давно був, рік тому. Раніше їздив у музеї,
відвідував виставки. З фотографами дружили.
Зараз якось уже холодніше стало.
Ми відчуваємо, що інформація, яка йде звідти, - це якась холодна війна.
Колишній мер Таураге Сігітас Мічуліс висловлюється  відвертіше.
У тому, що росіяни та литовці дедалі менше
розуміють один одного, він звинувачує політику Москви.
- Я думаю, й інші розуміють, що Росія велика і багато дала
в галузі мистецтва, культури, літератури цілому світу.
Але в даний момент політика Кремля дуже агресивна,
я думаю.
Не може так бути, що всі сусіди - вороги.
І Україна, і Грузія, і Молдова, Прибалтика, Литва, Польща.
Не може так бути. Така політика веде в нікуди.
Охолодження відносин відбувалося поступово.
Наприклад, через анексію Криму у 2014 році.
Що думають офіційні особи в Совєтську про сусідів,
DW з'ясувати не вдалося. Вони не знайшли час на інтерв'ю.
Ще кілька років тому в Литві і Росії вели переговори
про часткове скасування віз хоча б для прикордонного регіону.
Це могло б допомогти економічному розвитку
обох сторін, адже і там, і там є проблема відтоку молодого населення.
Але тепер ці переговори припинили
і ніхто не очікує, що найближчими роками щось зміниться.